shame is the gremlin who says
never good enough and if you can talk it
out of that one
who do you think you are the thing to
understand about shame is it's not guilt
shame is a focus on self guilt is a
focus on behavior shame is
i am bad guilt is i did something bad
shame is highly highly correlated with
addiction
depression violence aggression bullying
suicide eating disorders and here's what
you even need to know more guilt
inversely correlated with those things
shame
for women is this web of unattainable
conflicting competing expectations about
who we're supposed to be
for men shame is not a bunch of
competing conflicting expectations
shame is one do not be perceived as what
weak but the truth is vulnerability is
not weakness
i define vulnerability as emotional risk
exposure uncertainty
it fuels our daily lives and i've come
to the belief this is my 12th year doing
this research
that vulnerability is our most accurate
measurement of courage if we're going to
find our way back to each other we have
to understand
and know empathy because empathy is the
antidote to shame
if you put shame in a petri dish it
needs three things to grow exponentially
secrecy silence and judgment if you put
the same amount of shame in a petri dish
and douse it with empathy it can't
survive
the two most powerful words when we're
in struggle
me too if we're going to find our way
back to each other vulnerability is
going to be that path
you